well it's that time again another year
has passed us by and with it has gone
another year of anime we got good shows
we got bad shows but the real question
is what are the moments that are going
to be
remembered 2023 was a year dominated by
absolute heavyweight shows just
completely taking over anime seemed
innoc capable whether you were a fan or
not successful liveaction adaptations
legendary series coming to an end memes
so many memes it feels like the
influence of a handful of shows have
truly seeped into mainstream pop culture
and only continues to grow from there
but there were still some other things
happening around our little sphere anime
fans continue to find any opportunity to
complain about CG this time even Demon
Slayer was catching Strays with viewers
complaining about how these fishes look
like an absolute joke how dare any
Animation Studio consider this
acceptable quality they cried meanwhile
in e gu
land this is what Peak CGI looks like
Tashi drew two lines and got 44 million
views 400k likes and 100,000 retweets
meanwhile I'm out here drawing at least
eight lines and I'm still waiting for
shown and jum to hit me up with that
manga Deal One Piece defied All Odds by
giving us a liveaction adaptation that
didn't suck while the Jiu-Jitsu fan base
came together to collectively say nah
I'd win which is what I think they say
when they ENT a contest of who can more
effectively spoil their [__] series
but they would probably win against this
random dude from mashall I am RADS Amos
I mean look at him he last like 2
seconds who the hell would play a
character like that probably some
dumbass hack for real though it's been
10 years now since I've been doing these
yearly anime Recaps I have gone through
a bloody decade of anime and a lot has
changed during that time I can only
imagine the wild things that were
happening in 2013 back then hay Miyazaki
finishes his latest feature film The
Wind Rises just before before announcing
his retirement from film making at the
ripe young age of about 197 years old so
that was a [__] lie there are a lot
of shows that didn't make my list this
year not because they weren't good but
because I didn't have much to say about
them other than it was good hell's
Paradise was fun so was mashall so was
Undead unlock one day I'm sure the West
will appreciate um mus as much as Asia
does today is not that day M kense
continued my favorite isekai story of
all time by having its main carrot to go
I cannot get it up people have been
trashing Rudy left right and center but
I think he's Prov he's a real gentleman
by showing that he never ever raises his
sword at a girl all right let's get to
my favorite shows of the year but before
we do a quick word from my sponsor
thepoke post thepoke post is a monthly
membership club delivering a box of
awesome topshelf good from under the
radar Brands every month they introduce
their members to cool new products based
on a preference quiz they fill out
they've got awesome clothes cool stuff
for your house camping and cooking gear
basically just high quality stuff in
every category 90% of their products
come from small Brands based right in
the US they're now offering new
membership program where you can get
really great deals all year round I'm
talking 30% off or more sometimes and
it's totally free to join you can also
previe your membership right before it's
sent you can decide if you want to keep
it swap it out for other products or
skip this month entirely for no charge
you only pay what you want this month
but fol sent me their H show box and
they must have been listening cuz not
only do I have everything here to make a
legitimate Taco I also haven't make my
own hot sauce kit and I have been
missing spicy food in Japan for so much
it's so hard to find good spicy food
here so you know what I'll just makeing
my myself they also sent me that
Checkmate box with this really cool
chess set and scorecard exactly what I
need to remind myself of my chess
victory over Conor to get a free mystery
gift with your first membership purchase
just click that link in the description
and enter gig up gift at the checkout or
go to bespokepost.com gigg thanks for
Miss spoke post for the sponsor and now
back to the
video the zombie genre is probably one
of the most saturated and overdone
genres you can find in any entertainment
me medium about 10 years ago yet somehow
in 2023 we still got an entirely fresh
and original take on it in zom 100 Z 100
tells the sad story of mapper employees
overworked and undervalued by the
company overlords that run their lives
it takes an entire zombie apocalypse for
a k attender to start living the life he
should have this show felt like a
personal call out for anyone who's ever
worked a dead-end job in their lives and
has daydreamed of something anything
happening to take away their
responsibility out of their hands even
if that thing is the end of the world
Akira personifies that feeling of pure
Freedom we all secretly wish we had that
feeling that breaks the shackle of
responsibility of having to go to work
of having to wake up for school the next
day Arin Jer looks at him and goes [__]
that guy which is embodied in one of the
most impressive opening episodes all
year where you could feel that every
single person working on it Channel
their passionate hatred of all the
previous employers that had ever wronged
them unfortunately it felt like a lot of
the hype got taken away largely due to
episode releases being plagued with
constant delays because of time slots
and supposed production issues oh hey
would you look at that even though the
show Lost some steam as it went on and
was erally a bit all over the place at
times it was still a fun little show I
think anyone could enjoy because in this
day and age where it feels like people
are fighting tooth and nail just to
survive I think a lot of us could use a
story about one man reminding us all how
to
live the most respected genre in anime
but this year we saw the 100 girlfriends
who love you come along and personally
made sure that it never will be this is
the story of a man who got rejected so
many times who had such negative rizs
God took pity and gave him a hundred
different girls he had to date or they'd
all die this was like watching someone
dying of thirst in the desert and then
God goes all right I've got a solution
I'm listening just [__] drown him but
what God didn't plan for is that he
chose someone who could chug the ocean
dry and still have room for more 100
girlfriend has a concept so dumb it
would need to be as batshit crazy as his
own premise to even have a chance at
making it work and that's exactly why it
does it's stupid it's unhinged it knows
exactly how how insane it is and then
runs with it 10 km past where it needed
to go by all means this show shouldn't
have worked if we didn't have the
greatest Haron protagonist to bring it
all
together yes we were Grace with the Apex
of boyfriends the partner she tells you
not to worry about he may look like the
most unthreatening guy possible but
watch him be like don't worry I come in
peace hi what's your name peace it's
rare for me to laugh at a comedy anime
and even rarer when it comes to low brow
Haron romcoms but 100 girlfriends was a
Showcase of how to do a parody correctly
reinforced by Biber Animation Studio
doing a bang up job selling all of these
jokes in the anime adaptation they went
above and beyond and I can't wait to see
how they adapt the manga beyond the whoa
whoa wait what what why are you running
[Music]
away in the minds of of anime fans 3D
animation comes in two tiers there's the
berser 2016 tier a show so disastrous it
has scarred the anime Community from 3D
anime to this day and then there's this
the aesthetic that looks like one of
those games I apparently won't last 5
Seconds playing the real ones know
though that studio Orange has been out
here creating their own tier every
project they seem to continually push
themselves one up themselves and Trigun
Stampede is their best looking show yet
not just with some of the jaw-dropping
action sequences and camera work but
small micro expressions and Camera
animation they give their work just a
bit more life they are still continuing
to push the boundary of what is possible
in a 3D anime in every way possible when
I got the lucky opportunity to talk to a
producer at Studio orange he called
themselves the hentti of the anime
industry and well that's pretty accurate
because what they've done with tri gon
stamped has got me bricked up all right
but how's the
show Trion is one of the most beloved
anime from the old school Adult Swim era
and when you take on the mantle of
rebooting a franchise like this you
always have to contend with picky fans
comparing each and every little change
in detail vash's Bounty is way smaller
he has a different haircut different gun
character designs that looked like this
now look like this huh now where have I
seen this aesthetic before Oh The
Spaghetti Western Field takes a backseat
to fully flesh out a hard sci-fi story
it's more dark more gritty one of my
favorite things from the original being
vashan wolf Wood's epic buddy cob
Dynamic feels a tad more intense I'll
skin you alive and play with your bones
until your begging to die you got that
straight W make no mistake this is an
entirely new try gun but one thing I can
always respect is when a reboot tries to
do something different that the original
didn't already do and by the end of the
season it becomes abundantly clear what
all these changes were leading up to and
God damn did it leave me wanting more in
a time where I feel like we're getting
starved of good hard science fiction
anime this has to be one of the most
unique and interesting sci-fi worlds
we've seen in years and I honestly think
the way things are set up he has the
chance to do even more than the original
did if it gets future Seasons when
people remember trygon they say oh yeah
TR gun I freak loved TR gun but if you
asked them before that what they
recommended we go back and watch Cowboy
bbop Full Metal Alchemist Tri gun has
always been on that second or third
echelon of recommendations behind the
classics and I fully believe that with
what studio orange have set up with this
season it has the potential to go up to
this
[Music]
tier
there were a few anime last year that
exploded onto the scene as fast as
Oceano did our hearts were Torn To Shred
in a tragic 90-minute opening episode a
new metal was formed as anime company
saw the featurelength opening Premiere
and said wait you can do that it's free
real estate the opening song became the
very first Japanese song to top the
global Billboard 100 charts the people
of my anime list came together and went
[__] you for Metal Alchemist this is the
greatest anime ever made then everyone
remembered there was an entire rest of
the show you needed to watch describing
the plot of voko is like all right so
there's a Doctor Who's a huge fan of
this one
Idol really traumatic so it's an idol
anime no sometimes OKO is a victim of
his own insane premise like I don't even
know if I fully understand this main
character a grown ass Idol obsessed man
who gets reincarnated as the son of the
girl he idolized and grows up being
obsessed with his now Mom and any other
girl who even remotely reminds of her
like if I call him a [__] is he
more likely to say [__] you or yes
please here's a feed of Sigman Freud's
grave right now but behind all that the
show shines as this interesting no
[__] Instagram filters off look at
the Japanese entertainment industry
showing you what really happens behind
those closed doors when the cameras are
turned off I hate the
media this was the show that tricked
everyone into thinking they were
watching another Idol anime when in
reality it was almost the complete
opposite and the real ones know the true
thing single-handedly elevating the
reputation of Idol fans in 2023 is the
sheer existence of AI Toto with how
popular this Gods I find it interesting
how much I heard this title being thrown
around last year when most people saying
it probably didn't even know what an
Oshi noo is see in Japanese Oshi means a
person who I support and in Idol culture
is normally used to refer to someone's
favorite Idol so the term osoko has a
clever double meaning that could be my
favorite Idol or my Idol's children
which both perfectly describe the show
basically what I'm trying to say is
oshi's are worshiped in Idol fandom in
the same way that Taylor Swift has
become the Jesus for white
woman
I
am
at saying you're a fan of isi feels a
bit like saying you're a fan of British
food people think you're consuming the
most Bland tasteless piece of garbage
the world has ever seen but sometimes I
have a friend come visit and they have a
taste of a proper full English breakfast
a perfectly cooked Sunday roast they try
some of our Cornish pasties our crisps
and it's like damn this is pretty good
actually that is my Eminence in Shadow
this takes every single trashy cliche
tropes you scoff at in isekai and wears
it like a badge of honor edgy main
character an army of girls in his Haron
blatant power fantasy nonsensical plot
lines cheesy dialogue boobs you know it
shouldn't work but it wears it all so
proudly you start getting convinced that
it's actually cool it's not that it
isn't stupid it is stupid but it doesn't
give a [__] if you care or not and I
thought this would eventually run its
course until I kept watching and realize
that this has a more interesting plot
and better World building than 90% of
eai out there which actually says less
than you think for a self-aware as it is
it spares no expense in building up this
fully fleshed out world with so many
moving Parts every new arc you see the
Domino's being perfectly laid out it's
all set up for Sid to come in and top
with them on the biggest stage possible
and even though you know it's happening
when the moment comes it delivers every
single time this was the most fun I had
with any show all year and just when I
think the plotters know where else to go
season 2 ends with a world shaking
development that made me go [__] why
more isai doing this I guess what I'm
trying to say is I really miss
Gregs one man's freedom is another man's
genocide Aaron jger probably Attack on
Titan ended this year and the internet
had opinions if you already browse
Twitter you might have thought half the
people either think this was a
masterpiece ending no flaws 10 out of 10
we all won we all lost Aaron is a bird
or the sending ruin the series ruin the
characters the entire show pointless
spat on the legacy of everything he had
done no one's going to remember Attack
on Titan now Aaron is a bird today we're
going to talk about how to stop smoking
crack now with real people I've actually
talked to the consensus seems to be that
this was a satisfying conclusion that
did everything it needed to do I had my
slight nitpicks with the execution of
this ending but absolutely none of it
took away from my love for this series
as a whole what Attack on Titan has
achieved and the impact it's had on the
global reach of anime is something that
will go down in history as one of the
defining shows of this era this this
might not be my favorite ending of all
time but it is certainly the ending to
one of my favorite anime of all time so
for one last time thank you attack on
Titan only those around now will know
that feeling of after years of waiting
through final seasons of final parts of
final episodes 2023 was that time we
could definitively say that this was the
final bit of Attack on Titan will ever
get to sell God damn
it
[Music]
sometimes you just need a dose of
wholesomeness to brighten up your day
but being a dude watching anime can
sometimes feel like so what anime have
you been watching oh I'm watching this
anime called Skip and Loa and it's just
one of the most cute and
adorable yo you catch the latest episode
of Judit kis at all there was nothing in
2023 that made me come out of every
episode feeling as good as Skip and
loafer did this [__] was a weekly
injection of sunshine into my veins I
mean just look at this opening alone the
colors The Vibes the catchy song This
godamn Dance it's it's enough to make
any grown ass man internally scream this
is so
cute [__] yeah violence am I right Lads
skipping loafer is about as
straightforward as you can get a country
bumpkin moves to the big city and adjust
to her new high school life it doesn't
need any complex plot because it exudes
this air of authenticity that makes you
feel so godamn good it's rare to find an
anime as genuine as this one because
when I say high school life I don't mean
your typical cuty anime high schoolers
that are
like these are teenagers real teenagers
just enjoying their lives to the fullest
no melodrama no overly anime [__]
this is Youth and Adolescence that is
most pure without feeling like it's been
put through some MOA anime filter and
there's just something so endearing
about thata come why would I be
interested in teenagers look as a
certified man wait that line sounded
really wrong look as a certified man
baby pretending to be a grown-up let me
tell you adulting sucks we have jobs we
have responsibilities we have godamn
taxes sometimes you yearn for a time
when life was simpler and more straight
forward and maybe that time is
romanticized maybe you're looking back
at that time through Rose tinted glasses
but whether you are or you aren't you'll
never know because we'll never be able
to get that time back again ever and
it's those little moments those simple
times you cherish and reminisce about
that this show encapsulates perfectly
like there's this one scene where our
main girl comes home for the first time
during her summer break she stayed up
way too late catching up with her
friends and slept in but it's all right
her mom's taken the day off and she has
the whole summer ahead of her so on this
boiling hot day her mom slices her up a
watermelon and the episode slows down to
a crawl as we see her just taking a
moment to enjoy this watermelon while
the sounds of Summer ring on in the
background and she just stops and just
appreciates
and just like that her summer was
over when anime wants you to know one of
its characters is crazy it
goes when anime is trying to hint at
something important it's
like H there it was me all subtlety in
anime is using a chainsaw to dice an
onion but what happens when a show comes
along that treats you like you have the
IQ that Rick and Morty fans say they do
you get Heavenly delusion here is a show
that doesn't take you by the hand and
leads you but leaves you to discover the
story on your own it drops you into this
insane World gives you a handdrawn
scribble of a map and says figure it out
yourself it's episode 1 boom we see a
Duo exploring a ruin into Tokyo that
gets in some kind of altercation with
some Bandits all right you get the idea
it's some post apocalyptic world people
are fighting for survival and uh would
you look at that oh I am and I like what
I see what are you ladies doing you're
praying this doesn't have the ugly
bastard tag on it the girl brings out a
gun that looks like this and immediately
gears start turning wait is this some
sci-fi World [__] or is that a damn
Fisher Price Toy you think the baners
start attacking anyway and they fight
back so you're like ah okay maybe she
was just bluffing so this is just a
normal World After
All oh that's a gun gun in a single
scene the show us set up its World got
you asking questions played with your
expectations answered your question left
you needing more answers or without
directly telling you a godamn thing this
is Heavenly delusion for all 13 episodes
this had one of the most intriguing
worlds of any show this year but trusted
you to piece everything together
yourself there is no wasted scene no
outof character moment everything is a
possible puzzle piece that Clues you
into the bigger picture what happened to
this world why are there nightmares
creatures that are eating people what
kind of sick experimentations is going
on behind the scenes were you paying
attention even now cuz you just saw a
random drawing of a fish with legs that
looks oddly like this horrific thing and
the real question is did you see a
connection without me saying anything
only by watching intently do you realize
how many Crumbs are hidden in plain
sight you get given enough to get a
rough idea but never enough to see the
full picture and it's that unknown that
makes this world as intriguing as it is
godamn terrifying by the end we've only
just seen a slice of the larger hole but
it's so refreshing to see an anime that
will have your neurons firing in a way
where you don't have to worry about
watching with headphones on for once
you know most of the
time and I don't want to watch these
Chinese cartoons but in 2023 anime went
all right but what if we had Chinese
cartoons Japan Apothecary daries is an
anime that takes place in ancient China
not China in a palace setting that
immediately reminded me of these badly
dubbed Chinese soap opos I sometimes
walk into my mom watching as a kid at
the beginning I didn't fully realize
what the big hook of this show was was
it the House MD style medical detective
stories was it the historical drama
surrounding the palace politics yes but
on top of that he has simply put the
best female character we could find all
year and sometimes that's all it takes
for far too long anime seems to think we
want only one thing and it's this no how
about nothing more than just a
well-written believable compelling
female
protagonist and this Mal ma is a
character that deserves to be in the
running for one of the best protagonists
we saw in 2023 and was such a breath of
fresh air to see her presence was
overpowering without conforming to what
a lot of shows seem to think a good
female character is it's not that she's
not like other girls or premium wfu bait
or a strong female character trademark
she's just a girl a well-written
believable one that doesn't forget that
she's a person first before being just
another girl she doesn't have to be
unfeminine to find the overly
flirtatious attitude ude of some pretty
boy unappealing she cannot be your
typical Wu bait and still absolutely
slay when she needs to she's not strong
because she can beat up 100 guys but
because she's headstrong in her own
values and beliefs here is a clever
realist to acknowledges her place in the
palace hierarchy but isn't afraid to
throw hands when [__] needs to get done
God damn my girl just factory reset that
[__] seeing Malu passionately solve
these medical Mysteries while asserting
her [__] dominance all over the
palace politics made this such a
compelling watch and hopefully more
shows will be able to take note of great
characters like
[Music]
this appreciating the statue of David up
close getting to see Lono Messi dribble
pass five players watching Jack
Nicholson command every scene he's in it
doesn't matter what the subject matter
is it's always enthralling to see an
absolute master of their craft at work
and that's the exact feeling I get
whenever I get to see anything written
by nauki osawa and Pluto was absolutely
no exception I once created a robot that
was perfect the realest robot the world
has ever
seen there are only a few manga that can
boast such a legendary status as uraro
himself when you have a track record of
titles like monster an absolute
Masterpiece with arguably the greatest
villain anime has seen 20th century boys
not just my favorite manga of all time
but one of my favorite pieces of fiction
to exist Pluto is meant to be one of his
weaker Works according to Die Hard fans
and godamn this is him operating at his
lowest potential this is like sending in
your weakest fighter and that fighter
turns out to be Gojo [__] saturo and
wait yeah that allergy checks
out this has all the calling cards of a
classic urosa tale he sets the stage a
Sci-Fi world where humans and robots
coexist a series of unsolved murders a
detective that is missing part of his
memories a robot that has done the
impossible and taken a human life he
hooks you into his world and leaves you
with a single question when the first
episode ends just how deep does this
Rabbit Hole go the man's ability to
construct a mystery and Captivate an
audience through his Mastery of suspense
to me has the same level of
craftsmanship as seeing a master
blacksmith make a legendary sword every
episode is so dense with emotion a plot
that will keep you guessing through all
the twists and turns sitting on top of
the sheer thematic depth of the story
that every single character carries on
their back and by the end of it all
he'll leave you with these ideas that
you'll be thinking about far after the
credits role this is some of the finest
storytelling you can find anywhere if I
had to make a guess why this didn't make
as big of an impact as it probably
should have well this was an adaptation
of a Sci-Fi manga that was written 20
years ago that was originally a
reimagining of asteroid boy a manga that
came out 60 years ago so inevitably
there might be some aspects that feel a
bit dated what's this a war involving
the invasion of some Middle Eastern
country predicated on the possible
developments of robots of mass
destruction
H oh hey there's a guy called
Adolf he's a bad guy I couldn't agree
with you more my dear Adolf but along
with a slightly lukewarm ending this
doesn't take away from the legacy of one
of the greatest mangas alive right now
so I have one question left are we ready
to attempt a 20th century boys
anime domain
[Music]
expansion when you watch an action you
normally go through a season where you
might see a ton of great action but you
know it all builds up to this one or are
most two episodes where the production
value Skyrocket and you're treated to
this insanely animated fight that will
drop your jaw to the floor these are the
scenes that everyone remembers and
defines the top fights of the Year
jiujitsu Kon went how about we do
that for every single
episode I don't think I've ever quite
experienced the collective adrenaline
field ride J Tyson season 2 has given me
youron on an episode and be watching
some of the sickest [__] that's ever
been put on screen and you think to
yourself there's no way they could ever
top this and it's at that moment the
show will look you dead in the eye and
go I'll [__] do it again and then it
does again and again and again and again
and again and again so many amazing
moments so many sick ass scenes Midway
through the season the hype got to me
and I excitedly tweeted out it should be
godamn illegal for an anime to go this
hard that was the same day all this came
out one of the biggest talking points
has been mappis treatment of their
animators during the season and I think
it's a testament to The Blood Sweat and
tears poured into this that we got a
product this fantastic despite the
hellish working conditions they were
going through Demon Slayer mob psycho
this may not have gotten the opportunity
to be as polished as shows like that but
it is unmatched when it comes to its raw
stylistic flare every single fight has a
unique identity not constrained to one
genre of action we got gritty
hand-to-hand combat Citywide disaster
level brawls insanely unique powers idle
dance beatdowns there was a mecha fight
a [__] Mecha fight in a Shonen anime
the amount of hype the amount of [__]
sheer disrespect we got [__] rabbits
throwing hands this was one of the
greatest showcases I've ever seen of for
lack of a better term [__] cool [__]
this felt like the purest celebration of
fight scenes and choreography we were in
the audience they got to Marvel at a
symphony of some of the coolest set
pieces you can find in the medium The
shib Arc may not have been Peak
storytelling or the peak of all Shonen
arcs but right now this is the peak of
action
spectacle the way elves see this world
is a mystery I thank you freen it's
solely because of you that this retired
hero could have one final
[Music]
Adventure freen opens on the story of an
elf girl who takes for granted the time
she has with the people around her
decades pass in the blink of an eye her
companions age and before she has the
chance to fully get to know them they're
gone it's a regretful poignant taale
that shoots straight to your godamn soul
and then the opening is
[Applause]
[Music]
like the show took a different approach
to Fantasy Adventure while encapsulating
everything that the genre is about there
might not be any Demon Lord to defeat or
world to save but instead we have a
journey about appreciating the smaller
things in your life the beautiful things
you might have missed if you forgot to
look for them I showed this to a mate
and he was like freen you mean side
quest the anime and I bloody ate him
because of how [__] accurate that is
yet it's through those detours you take
along the road to your destination that
freen absolutely shines it's the type of
show that grips you without ever needing
to hit you with any flashy
high-intensity action scenes to keep
your attention and then hit you with
these flashy high intensity action
scenes this series didn't need to go
hard in this animation in any way shape
or form but chooses to do so anyway this
is what it's like to watch a fully
polished product but like fren's own
Journey these are not the moments that
stick with you for the world saving
Adventure she went on the slice of
memories we get are those small moments
that really defined the time she spent
with her party and as she forms new
bonds you start to see those small
pieces she begins to pick up from the
people around her that slowly become a
part of her this is what every fantasy
tale aspires to be it's shows like these
that somehow make you nostalgic for an
experience you've never had friends
you've never made but at his heart it's
a gentle reminder to cherish the things
in your life that really matter to make
the most of the time with the people you
truly
[Music]
value an I have killed so many
people I will be
reborn and I will atone for all
LIF that's all we've ever won want it
something in this world that can give us
a reason to keep
going when I was a kid my father would
read me bedtime stories that my childish
mind would always be absolutely immersed
in accounts of hungry hungry
caterpillars rainbow fishes ugly
ducklings these were the greatest
stories I'd ever heard cuz they were but
it would always end off with a message a
seed that got planted in my head that
would hopefully Sprout into a less that
would stick with me and as you grow
older start learning new lessons by
experiencing real life you forget the
effect that stories can have on you a
good story can not only Entertain You it
can move you give you a new perspective
teach you something you never knew you
could learn that you can take far beyond
the confounds of watching some piece of
entertainment that is the power of a
great tale and that is everything that
villain Saga season 2 encapsulates I
cannot begin to describe the sheer
effects this show had on me season 1 was
a compelling Adventure filled with
tragedy Vengeance and violence so to
anyone coming into this season blind you
probably would have been taken back the
violence takes a backseat to a pure
methodical character drama Vengeance has
been replaced by a saga of redemption
and acceptance honor glory sacrifice all
left by the wayside and All That Remains
is people just trying their best to find
their place in this merciless World
While most series would cower at the
thought of Shifting Gears this
drastically it is that strong ju
position that gives villain saga's
message the weight it has exemplified by
possibly the greatest character
development we've ever seen in this
medium thorin's transformation is
something that transcends entertainment
a man who starts off as a shell of a
human broken empty Unworthy of
redemption but through every person he
meets every relationship he forms he
starts to learn to pick up the broken
pieces of his former self that slowly
but surely fill his soul up as you see
him encounter conflict you'll secretly
wish for that instant gratification that
he will revert back to his previous
Savage self but as you witness this
journey of a man fighting so desperately
to find peace who learns that it's okay
not just to forgive others but to
forgive himself as well it becomes an
experience that will lingle with you and
invites you to find your own Solace
watching Vinland Saga feels like I'm
getting read the greatest bedtime story
ever told by my dad it'll grip you with
the pi of tales packed with nothing but
raw human emotion that will leave your
heart filled to the brim and by the end
of it all it gives gives you something a
message a lesson it earnestly hopes you
can take with you it reminds you that
change isn't just something that exists
in the boundaries of a fictional story
it doesn't come easy it's a long hard
unforgiving road but you can get there
even if every day you only take one
small step at a time we will always find
a reason to fight each other no matter
what time period we are in weapons we
can use or tools we have at our disposal
but no matter how broken you think the
world is there is still meaning in in
trying to build a better tomorrow maybe
tomorrow I can make a brighter day come
maybe tomorrow I can be just that little
bit Kinder maybe tomorrow I can become a
slightly better version of myself you
are capable of letting go of that hatred
even if that hatred is towards
yourself you have no
[Music]
enemies